[Music]
in case you haven't noticed moviegoers
can't stop freaking out over spider-man
no way home it's been a while since a
movie's release yet it continues to
dominate the pop culture conversation
fans have heaped praise on its laundry
list of cameos and incredible fan
service but even without those moments
the film apparently stands on its own as
one of the best mcu films cementing
itself as many people's favorite movie
of 2021 and there's one specific scene
in no way home that has left many people
salivating for more tom holland's third
standalone movie as spider-man serves as
a launching point for many of marvel's
phase four plans for one it sets up the
multiverse shenanigans that will take
place in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness while the movie
also introduces an mcu version of the
fan favorite character matt murdock with
one eye on the future then many fans
have been singling out one story arc
that they'd love to see revisited
towards the end of no way home there's a
moment between all three of its
spider-men in which they discuss all the
traumatic things that they've been
through over the years when it comes
time for garfield's peter to reveal his
greatest loss the death of gwen stacy he
describes having grown bitter in the
years after her passing and claims that
he even stopped pulling his punches this
moment has sparked countless ideas and
fan theories on social media and has
left many viewers wanting to know more
about what garfield's parker did during
this dark unseen stage was life in a
reddit discussion about no way home one
user wrote does anyone else want to see
a follow-up on andrew's spider-man after
he said he got bitter and stopped
pulling his punches one reply to that
comment read yes i remembered after
watching how dark he went after uncle
ben died in the amazing spider-man
imagining him struggle to keep afloat
after the amazing spider-man 2 and
failing would be so gut-wrenching the
last time we saw andrew garfield's
spider-man prior to no way home he was
right back in the swing of things ready
to save the city from rhino's rampage
you want me to come down there so you
can kill me yes i'll be right there ah
there's no place like home
so is it possible that we'll ever see
what he got up to after that final
showdown well while it's clear that fans
want more of garfield spider-man it's
unclear if they'll ever get their wish
nevertheless they certainly have plenty
of ideas of how the amazing spider-man 3
could work after all it's now been
established that previous marvel movies
not set within the mcu proper exist in
alternate universes theoretically the
amazing spider-man franchise could
continue solely under sony's umbrella
giving garfield's character closure
while setting up a new story arc to pay
off that line in your way home but
that's not the only way in which andrew
garfield could make his return to the
franchise some marvel fans have
suggested that the amazing spider-man 3
could manifest as part of another story
in the sony universe of spider-man
characters on a separate reddit thread
one user posits they need tom hardy's
venom squaring up against someone don't
they they should just do a venom vs
spidey movie with garfield and then
maybe a team up between the two it would
definitely scratch some itches fans have
to see venom and spidey go toe-to-toe on
the big screen once again and it doesn't
necessarily close any doors for the
symbiote to wreak havoc in the mcu
either marvel studios obviously have
their own plans for the symbiote as in
the mid-credits scene to no way home a
piece of eddies was left behind in the
mcu if kevin feige and company want to
do their own thing with the symbiote
there are plenty of other options to
choose from to keep their story distinct
from sony's as one redditer suggests i
think that's a good idea and then the
symbiote and the mcu can do something
different agent venom venom scorpion
something original etc and as marvel
fans know all too well at this point
anything is possible in the multiverse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]